joining me now is rudy giuliani former
new york city mayor um
rudy is this anything more
than a political hit job and a warning
shot
to others who dare question the leftist
authority right now in new york city
well i you know they're they're ruining
the city completely
and it's a it's a tragedy and i think
everyone in the city knows it
and i mean there are so many things for
for latisha james to investigate
for example mayor de blasio's wife can
account for 900 million dollars
in a in a organization that i started
and bloomberg continued
and he ruined it's called he named it
thrive new york
which really seems to be thrive somebody
we don't know who
nobody's investigating that laura that's
900 million dollars
in new york city the city council went
crazy when they found out about it
and now nobody wants to talk about it so
that could that could
easily be investigated the nra is
ridiculous
it's absolutely ridiculous what she's
doing and she's seeking capital
punishment
for uh whatever she claims are the
errors well just so rudy just so people
know
how she's justifying her lawsuit so
people get what
her so-called logic is this is what she
said
why call for the dissolve for it to
dissolve instead of just the removal of
these people and try to keep this
organization attack because the
corruption was so broad
and because of the level of waste and
because they have basically
destroyed all of the assets of the
corporation it was critically important
that one of the causes of actions and
one of the remedies that we are seeking
is the dissolution of the nra isn't this
just
a lawsuit to crush an influential
conservative organization
in an election year rudy of course it is
i mean she's a poor excuse for a lawyer
anyway
and she ran on a single uh issue which
was get trump
rather inappropriate for an attorney
general just attorney to run to get one
person
and now this case against the nra the
nra brought suit against her
my money is on the nra i wouldn't bet on
her legal acumen anyway but um
the react the reality is that this is
just a
silly lawsuit she's got real scandals to
look at the one i mentioned
900 million that went to obama's wife
and the charity she was running no
nobody has the guts to look at that not
the d.a
who's turned out to be another political
hack sorry it's
vance i mean he's just a complete
politician
not a what does this all mean to the
city just
it's kind of funny to see cuomo begging
people to come back to the city
but for all of us they can't govern
themselves
what happens to new york it means what
governor pataki said about ten days ago
he and i you know did everything we
could to turn this place around and did
he said this the city's gonna city's
gonna be finished if de blasio keeps
going in this direction
it's not going to be revivable you can't
drive away
this much capital so quickly you can't
have
a crime rate to go up i mean i
i brought murder down the first year i
do to 20
he brought it up 24 percent now
how do you keep up with that
like that there's now graffiti all over
the city of new york
it's so it's so depressing for all of us
for all of us who have
you know either have lived in new york
or work in new york it's
it's a heartbreak and and tonight our
message to america is
this can happen to where you live if you
make the wrong decisions
politically this this is not just going
to be confined to new york
if if the biden gang gets in charge rudy
this kind of retribution campaign is
going to be sweeping the country
and i mean the midwest too last word oh
absolutely
there will be uh criminalization of
politics in the worst way
and there will be deterioration like you
see in new york and chicago and
baltimore and
that's that's our future if we elect
biden and the democrats no doubt about
it
rudy the difference between new york
when you were mayor
and all of us were still young in the
city
and now it is just a heart it's a i mean
i say it it's
i'm angry about it but i'm heartbroken
as well for the people it's my heart too
it is a heartbreak rudy thank you so
much a lot of hard work
a lot of hard work